me
ah slow down it's dangerous in here
ingredients don't stay fresh for long
get them
uh
we need to get going before they expire
she's quite the fighter seems foraging
for ingredients takes more than just
luck
ah
i'm so sorry
no one escapes by
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
huh
told you i'd win
huh
[Music]
what
[Music]
huh
you've been a naughty boy
blitz
look over there the icicles up ahead are
falling
uh let's be careful not to get hit it
will definitely hurt
don't be such a brute
you're in for a little shot
come a little closer
[Music]
[Music]
huh
nice and spicy
aha this must be it
oh it's huge
this is perfect come to me my little
treasure
[Music]
my ingredients are attacking me
help me put him in his place
not so hard not so hard
up dinner time even better
if it's paired with a bit of your
version
wait there's something else here this
must be the boy that hunter was
put piemon's never seen one with this
pattern before
where have i seen this before hmm
aha it was in the historia naturalis of
lewe
this pattern is unmistakable it belongs
to a breed of boar that went extinct 300
years ago wow
how is this one still alive after could
be i read that this boar was hunted to
extinction because its meat was
condensate of jumbo cryo slime right
[Music]
huh
foreign
ugh
[Music]
300.
oh are you yes for the millionth time
yes but i don't know any of the people
you're looking for
that is not possible they are this is
strange
what is going on what is it
how long surely not hundreds of years
uh does that really make sense oh
still it's hard to believe but it
doesn't seem like there's any
okay so what's olaf
olaf oh i'm i can't remember which
generation it was from but
so a great great what an unusual term
reunited olaf do you want ah
yes that remind you should come with me
oh
we're ready to cook are you i was born
ready oh and sick fria will be my then
let the cooking
and don't worry much appreciated well
then
wait of course ah pymon doesn't remember
applying for
okay
our first problem is ingredients i've
got it
right and we can go find me a radish
let's wash the radish in the river
go fetch me some
slimes scared the teasers out of pymon
this is way too close to the venue what
if they serve
trouble during the competition
uh i don't think we should risk it go
get them
get the fire under control without using
water though or this dish is a goner
[Music]
uh
oh this is practically also i make me a
mushroom chicken skewer
and make sure just make it
[Music]
what
um the meat is on track but we're aiming
for perfection here
a certain one a certain yes definitely
needs some
i just mean it would be let me see
regional spec yes something that's i
don't care if it fly
all right
ugh
thanks you guys
[Music]
i almost forgot side dish are you sure
it's no trouble
here and is this the recipe yes this
is so the technique doesn't matter and
you must be passionate about
i trust you guys the confident
come on this is the
uh
[Music]
yes
this was both chef's dishes today where
nothing short of exception but
this is a competition and there can only
be one winner
and that with shang ling
i win i thought i was sure to win with
pork chops so fresh they were
practically still grunting
but it turns out that's still no match
for the taste of extinct
boar excuse me yep
my goodness the amount you'd make if you
sold this could support
everything the main thing is that you
enjoyed eating it
anyway now our judge has meanwhile
losing is no fun but it was worth it for
the chance to eat such superb cooking
this is gorgeous too we're it not for
that exquisite foreign excellent
side dish it's hard to say if i still
would have won pie monster
hmm i will have it oh
this is the taste of spring
hey now the boar maybe
but the taste isn't putting a smile on
customers faces
is what a good time was had by all
but everyone's gone now let's go and say
goodbye to zhang
thanks you guys without your help i
don't know how it would have gone today
and without you my mom wouldn't have
gotten to try so many new tasty snacks
also wouldn't have gotten so full not
sure i'll probably start heading back to
louie
but i might change my plan on the way i
don't like to plan things too thoroughly
who knows maybe you'll bump into me out
in the wild again zhang wing's gone from
boom shop you are a gifted chef come and
visit me at the one man restaurant some
and if you want
i'll teach you how to cook some it's a
deal
see you again soon